the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay let's get started briefly recap
what we're talking in the last lecture
we emphasize the density of states which
is a measure of how many quantum states
either per frequency interval or per
energy interval or pair B vector
magnitude in the world wavelengths
interval that's your choice and it's
really a mathematics when I want to find
the sum of quantity F over all or the
possible set of combination kxkykz
each set of this combination gives me
one quantum state if I include in this P
polarization or spin as my Edition or
say polarization general I call this
polarization right so when I do this
summation I'm summing all the quantum
states and when this function that's not
very rapidly
over two adjacent point of this K I can
convert this summation into integration
so the density of state is really
mathematical convenience and but it's a
it's a so widely used a very very
powerful tool so many times that we talk
about just so people would say what's
the dots
I mean you calculate the tensed up state
cell from different mature systems and
later on I hope we'll say some of this
when we do the say computer we'll look
at what people are plotting right and
then we used simple relationship so
depends on this function is this
function a function of a ye of function
okay so you decide that whether which
one is the most convenient for you
whether you convert this into e or K
integration and there is a relation so
to do that conversion from K into e
this relation between the energy and the
wave vector for electron we use a simple
parabolic band and for fall and photon
is an inner dispersion that we use with
that we did a mass and say what's the
corresponding things up States so that's
then the emphasize we spend the most out
of time there and also we give example
if you have quantization right the
separation of energy level let's say in
the Z Direction becomes very large
I cannot convert this summation into
integration anymore
keep that some but I still do in the XY
direction I still can convert that into
integration so we show the difference in
the density of states of a 2d quantum
well versus a bulk say parabolic by
mature and at the end of the last
lecture we move down to talk about Fermi
Dirac fermion to rock distribution this
is a now I have quantized energy levels
starting from if you recall in the first
chapter we introduced the board's main
factor the probability of a molecule
having certain energy and now we
expended that we see this is the Gibbs
factor there's a probability for a
quantum state say being occupied
I'll see say with energy E and with the
number of particle n so it's an open
system right and the constant
temperature and mule is the chemical
potential that's the energy that it
takes to take out or put in a particle
at that energy say I into the system the
average energy so chemical potential
this is driving force for mass diffusion
right temperature is the driving force
for heat transfer and pressure is the
driving force for the volume change
those are the thermodynamic quantity
and we asked the question so when we
apply this we need to find the
normalization factor a because the
probability of adding up all possible
possibilities should give me 1 so when I
apply this to one quantum state of the
electron a charge so it's a fermion
right and this quantum state is in
thermal equilibrium with the surrounding
so in that quantum state right the
electrons and getting in get out is an
open system and there's a constant
temperature communication with the
surrounding electrons and if I apply the
probability summation I find the lumber
adhesion factor and eventually I find
the average average number of electrons
in that quantum state I is the Fermi
Dirac distribution yeah I'm a smear over
KBT exponential plus what actually the
what we ended last lecture right and I
will continue so this is a for fermium
right Fermi Dirac fermion in one quantum
state I can have empty no particle here
no electron there or I can have maximum
what right so those studies so that
summation is easy to do and now let me
extend that who a boson so with that I
will say if I suppose I is both an
Einstein distribution and again I
consider a quantum state with the energy
say this quantum state an energy e I
right and a boson are condoms for boson
one kind of state can have 0 to infinite
possibilities right it's not a firm
young the Pauli exclusion principle so I
can have the number of particles could
be 0 or 1 2 right so all at its end 1/2
0 the total energy of the system is 0 we
have one that's a AI e I and then when I
have to party where that's to e I that's
a total energy of the system right of
this specific energy level I created by
the system ok and again then I go to the
Gibbs factor I say the probability of
this quantum state having a particle
between 0 to infinite has to sum up
equal to 1 so I sum this up and small n
write chapter and to 0 to infinite
that's the ER a exponential mass e so
that depends on if I have n particle
I should have n times e I that's the
energy and the then I have n times mu
divided by KBT that equals 1 right
so now you take out this end you see II
I'm nice meal that factor is a common
factor and it's a geometric series right
so if I do my summation for this
geometric series I got a one master
exponent sure master II I my Samuel KB T
equals one
okay right so this is the the summation
of the geometric series and then I have
a equals 1 minus exponential mass e I'm
a small Kb T so this give me the
illumination factor a and with this I
have the probability of this state
what's the probability of this state
having n particles
see I can write it down and again I can
go to find the average number of
particles right so the average number of
particle I use F again this is a for
this energy level and either say
temperature and the chemical potential
meal for the whole system that's the
average number of particles and I should
be equal to the probability so is n P E
whether we have here e and the N and N
equals this N equals 0 to infinity
so I'm finding the average so this is a
when they say I average over this and
over the probability I just derived with
the romanization factor right so if you
sum this up you pray and a I equals 0 to
infinity and this is the end this is
myeloma realization the 1 mass
exponential masse I
Bozzio KBT and times to say exponential
that's the
against a and e i- n times Emile KBT and
that's the summation I should do okay
sum over all this end well there's a
small little a small mathematic trick
because a is here and is here right it's
not a simple geometric series and this
mathematical trick is if you if you take
this function here right and you do a
derivative with respect to Z I - Mew you
gather a in the front right if you if
you think of this as my X that's a
density is the ye mass n times X and you
take a derivative if you see that's my
function I take the derivative of that
function that n will come to the front
so with that you can do this submission
I'm not going to the matter detail you
can read the book and I'm going to give
you the final result of this exercise
will give you a I and T mule the average
number of particle for a boulder in one
quantum state in thermal equilibrium
with the surrounding right this is the
day III - mule KB key looks very similar
before I have therefore Fermi Dirac I
have plus one not have minus 1 so
Mathematica turns out the very beautiful
is just the difference between the two
particles one plus one is minus okay and
this is the Bose Einstein distribution
for say Einstein
and compared to a Fermi Dirac if you say
here
yeah I'm ass mule do I have a Kb T plus
1 right and because here is a plus 1
this is numerator the 1 right you say
for n here is always between 0 & 1 right
but that's another case for for the
Einstein distribution because this is a
minus 1 right so if we look harder they
typically how it looks like and say for
y let's say the Fermi Dirac distribution
and they because it's an exponential
function right KBT remark abdi room
temperature is 26 milli electron volt
okay and if this one yeah I'm as mule is
much larger than KBT this is very large
it's rumoured say if this is a leg here
that quickly can go to 0 right so you
plot it here is your mule and for fermi
dirac is 1 and pretty much all the way
right except the right end to the e
equals mule range were so this is a e of
the energy so the energy level and it's
only around the milk KBT range 3 KBT and
the rest of the is either 1 or 0 so aha
now if you think about that when we
discuss metal before right we say ok
this is your AF the this is your Fermi
level and Fermi level is actually very
close to the chemical potential mu I'll
comment that later on but see right
I just think this is the mule okay
and you see only 3 KBT near that level
you have see below this you have some
empty States normal is filled right
right a zero temperature field right to
this level but the long zero temperature
because that fermi-dirac distribution
there are few empty states below and
feel mobile electron ball okay so that's
they so you a matter a lot of electrons
are moving contributing and conduction
only near this EF so that's a 1 and now
if you think about the Buddha Einstein
distribution what it look like is here
is your mu and here's your Yi right and
I cannot have my e less than mu
otherwise the average number of
particles like here right so when e I
approach mule this approach 1 so that
labra could be really large right but
yeah it's a much larger than me oh this
quickly drop so this is my 1 I was
Einstein distribution okay so you
probably are heard bose-einstein
condensate right few years ago physics
department cattle er got lower price for
the work in Buda in Stockholm is it
right what is it
so if you look at this we go to very low
temperature right this KB T is very
small and 10 to the minus 5 Kelvin okay
and then when this one gets to say
really close to mule it turns out this
lumber is a it's getting really very
large the whole
this goes very large so there are what
they means is that there is this one
energy state that are all the particular
fall into that energy state one quantum
state right
so they condense into that corner state
that's the simple bose-einstein
condensate and the trick is you got to
gather that and say temperature really
really low so it turns out that that
let's say there was a I stand this was
predicted a very very long time ago but
nobody were able to drive to that
temperature in the physics department
and Keller and a few others have been
trying to drive this to very low
temperature for many years by using very
refrigeration technique okay gentle low
temperature and in fact they were beaten
they didn't win and they it was their
student and went to least right now
either Colorado both are nice right they
thought about way to do the
bose-einstein condensate much easier and
the way they did it is to use the laser
cooling okay why why you can cool a
laser you typically think about the
heating stuff right and so when you have
a laser beam coming in and what it does
is say is using this Doppler effect but
really pretty much like a using the
momentum of the photons and then when
the electron I say when the molecule
mode want to rush in the photon just
heat it so it doesn't look so pretty
much like make them stationary and when
they make a station or either you quit
their temperature is low so with that
they can be the cooling on say up your
table and gather bose-einstein
condensate so that the lower price were
given three people and two from NIST and
one from physics they the calor they did
a lot of will say
a beautiful experiment that using that
technique yes they live these well it's
not they have a net charge zero and that
is right they don't have the high
positive negative charge Marko's of and
yeah well this is what the let's say
here is a Fermi Dirac and here is a
distribution for both the Einstein book
for the Einstein right that's the F
right and so you should go out and be
the advisers that's why they so that's
they that's the one park right and in
fact that this laser cooling this is a
where Steven Chu got a lower price of
the current do you secretary right it
was he did this laser cooling experiment
and he he got a lower price on laser
Cooney so before they gave the
bose-einstein condensate lower price
they have to give the cooling of ice you
know wonder if you haven't done scaped
you goofed right and this is this last
year was a graphene and between graphene
and there is another one and this is a
you say common sixty that was a rip to
Richard Smalley and carbon six is a
carbon the other form of carbon atoms
arranged in like a soccer ball right and
in the 91-93 were lining one is a and
you see jima say Garuda's nanotubes
right
it didn't really grow he's just a
founder in the dust
and this was the say Cobham dust he
looked at the ATM and they found the
search tubes so that that's pretty much
like you another form of kaabah right
and so Japan I must say people a lot of
people say they probably get lottery
prize I actually wish to go road for
price but this skipped went to the
graphene you got a scotch tape scotch
tape that's the easier alright anyway so
first point right the distribution the
second is what's the chemical potential
for photons and fallen right and
typically we say for photon of unsane
motorola right the user argument is a
camera pod near 0 mu is 0
and the reason to argue that mu is 0 is
that say it's not a conserve the
particle right hold on for long you can
disappear
light can absorb that becomes say RC
heat say get the whole solar ready they
disappear
it's another electron is it's always the
somewhere it will somewhere but it
doesn't get destroyed so that's the
argument so there n you should not have
say because this is a changing right
that mu is a zero that's the argument
for typically is correct for thermal
radiation or for thermal photons right
mu equals zero but they say older years
I've been actually asking is struggling
with this because if you look at the
electronic device right so after
electronic device lasers and LEDs
and what happens to the lighting mission
in that case is the light as a new media
so you have conduction but you have
valence band right and see a light
electron goes from here to here while
you meet a full time that's an emission
right like and I electron from high
energy to lower energy they could come
or dad into photon emission process and
in laser and the LED it turns out the
electrons and the holes another in
equilibrium with each other and the
electron has a chemical potential a host
has a chemical potential and this is
also called the quasi fermi-level so EF
let's say and this is e FP right each of
them have a equipment their own if you
take them as a system they have a
chemical potential and in this case the
photon immediate actually has a camera
potential mu the MU equals the
difference of EF n EF p so your
distribution function is
here you should write this e I is H nu
right at a certain energy and the mass
mule so so in fact photons can indeed
have a chemical potential and that's
when they interact with other lung
equilibrium systems it like an electron
I'm not saying people discuss photon or
nobody has really probably encountered
that situation where photons are emitted
by let's say if I I could imagine if for
lance only photons by immediate the same
process by long including electron holes
I should write the same symbol for okay
but nobody has created a system like
that and maybe some people talk about
for long lasers that might be the that
might be you have to write that way okay
so those are they are statistical
distribution for electrons and photons
and now I'm going to use it so what we
have derived if you think about this is
I saw Schrodinger equation I know the
energy level I know the quantum state
right and they using density of states I
know
near each energy level how many states
they had and now I know using the
bose-einstein Fermi Dirac distribution
and now each quantum state how many
Parker's this is either thermal
equilibrium right I'm not talking about
long equilibrium case yet so I can count
the energy store in the system thermal
energy stored in the system okay so
let's do that
so let's look either the examples
my first example is photon blackbody
radiation okay let me say I have a
cavity right inside the cavity are
photons in equilibrium with the
surrounding I temperature T this is
actually if you go to Rey the punks book
you it's very interesting 9005 we
discussed those and photon itself how
could they reach her in Quinny burn so
you have to actually say maybe there's
some gas very dilute the atoms there and
they help you have that process right
but say let's say I have a cavity with
the photons in equilibrium at the time
thirteen right then what's the energy
total energy of this photons in the
cavity right so the total energy is yo
in this cavity is of course the
polarization of light and kxkykz
right that's a day KX that's the mode K
Y KZ that's what we are doing they we
say we need to convert this summation
into integration right instead of KX KY
KZ gives me one
stay right and each state say while
steady state will have a frequency Omega
right the energy of that one photon is a
chi omega right one photon but say on
each state how many photon higher is by
the Bose Einstein distribution so this
is a day Buddha Einstein
I the temperature T so this is the
frequency energy energy is it is ash neo
or Omega let me use the Omega Omega and
temperature Chi and I said it's a
thermal radiation blackbody mu equals
zero so I don't turn a mule okay so
that's what I need to do right and now
assuming you know how to do it last
lecture we spend time converting the
submission into integration so I'm going
to just write the integration I'm going
to use a density of states if you say at
the beginning we say it's converting
this summation into tens of states
I'm going to do the density of states in
the Omega frequency right so I'm going
to write this is it turns out that the
volume is here because it depends on if
I use a tense of states per unit volume
then say h-bar Omega F was our Iceland
distribution times D Omega and D Omega
right so I'm converting that summation
into an integration and my photon
frequency could be 0 to infinite so this
is my master okay
what we get let's do a few more steps
you can go to check so I could write
that yo / ways per unit volume what's
the energy density in terms of function
for frequency Omega right and I have if
you check 0 to infinite H bar Omega
exponential H bar Omega K BT minus 1 and
sit in some states for photon you can
look at your nose is Omega square
they speed a lot cubic and PI Square and
the Omega right
ah I should not put a 1 we got here this
is an integration already and what's
inside that is the function of Omega
right this is the energy density per
unit volume of those photons and what do
you have what you're saying inside is
essentially is the black body Punk's fly
body R additional it's very easy right
once you have what plunker is really say
you have to have that quantization to
get this kind of distribution and the
rest is just today I say each mode how
many photon comes from one energy one
fold huh times how many moves okay and
so that's the see here what's inside is
you Omega and normally we do not write
the Planck's law in terms of the energy
density we write the say emissive power
or writing in terms of intensity right
and well so here I have photons per unit
volume I know the energy of this photon
and this photon are moving to all the
rations blackbody radiation right at the
speed of light so what the intensity is
defined the per unit the ration unit
solid angle
what's the flux of energy so
intensity of light is a per unit solid
angle in space this is a piece of per
unit to ration their how much energy and
the total space solid angle is how much
for pi that's the whole right you know
in a plan this 2pi in your sphere is 4
pi so I have 4 pi that's a per unit
solid angle times u Omega
so that's the total energy and this
energy is moving at the speed of light
that gives me the intensity okay and if
you go to a book you normally don't
write into Omega in heat transfer we
don't like to write use of Omega we like
to use lambda wavelength right so the
relation is here going back to your
choose whether you choose Omega or you
choose lambda right you need to convert
this to a conversion so if you do lambda
I lambda is really Omega you can convert
your Omega into lambda because they say
we say Omega equals the same hundred K
equals say two PI over lambda right so
it's au you replace Omega and by unit
that will be careful because your
integration is the over D lambda so now
you have to do the Omega D lambda and
this gives me now I radio the typical
form is four pi H Bar C square and
lambda fifth power exponent sure H pass
a and Kb lambda T Monson one so this is
the form if you had say taken as a read
of course that talk about blackbody
radiation like it's a heat transfer
you've probably seen this and typically
we'll say this is a one constant that's
another constant so you're writing in to
given constant but those are all in
terms of the fundamental physical
constants right okay and you can see
here this is lambda T and in fact if you
Lorelei's this by also temperature to
the fifth power
this is also will be a function of
lambda t
so this play body radiation Punk's law
if you plot that as a function of lambda
all say is here and there's the peak
here number that he is about the three
thousand micron Kelvin right we mention
this before and let's say the sun's
temperature is about six thousand that's
why our eyes are sensitive because the
three thousand divided by six other
point five micron right the earth sister
the the solar system on earth we got
used to the evolutions towards looking
during the day looking at the Sun right
if you you can imagine if there's
intelligence in the other solar systems
that would be a different wavelength
depends on the temperature of the stand
there okay right so that's the blackbody
radiation and if you go to look at the
integration right this is a so you say
here is you integrate Omega Omega Omega
square right and this is 0 to infinite
so if you do your integration you can
say okay because it's a warming of over
T right I can get this exponential into
one variable X right so if I do h-bar
Omega K BT into my X then you say D I
say Omega is proportional to X right so
Omega will be proportional to x times T
so here if I do that this Omega will
give me 1 T write this Omega gave me t
to T Square this will give me another T
so what I have if I integrate it
I will get a yo equals T fourth power
whatever constant right this is a once
you convert it into intensity or in turn
music power which is the pi times
infinity
you got a Sigma T fourth power right so
you see all this those who are the
Winslow wing that love reprise
displacement more you go to check the
history and plunk at the lower price and
I do know Stefan
this is Stefan Boltzmann law right right
those were all empirical and it came out
the luxury out of this okay so now
that's a full time right let's look
either last for long it's very similar
so for Lance
and for photons I'm going to if you
recall the typical dispersion of falling
I have of course this is dispersion
after I say acoustic phonons but I'm
going to use the Debye model so here is
the frequency here is a wave vector pi /
e power a and this is my Debye model
Nina
very crude okay and this is omega D a
real crystal is isotropic each the
Russian there is a different lattice
constant right the Debye is actually
collapse of all three polarization
transfers launched earlier into one and
also make this crystal equivalently
isotropic so in fact I have to say this
is a mite the vial equivalent lattice
constant and I need to first to find out
what's the equivalent lattice constant
right and if I have say n atoms in the
crystal right and in terms of each atom
can do say if you say okay in terms of
the modes right or in terms of the let's
say the you have three directions right
so you have each direction so you
usually have three and modes so I have
three n modes in total
right transfers to transfers when
non-sugar and now I need to make the
equivalent say you new CEO to generate
the same number of modes so what what
does it mean that means if I have three
n that's the number of modes right and I
sum up the polarization is a p3 I have K
X K Y KZ that x 1i some other each wise
issue set up K X K Y KZ gives me one
mode and that plus P polarization three
right so if you do that and you can
again you write it in terms of density
of states so is the volume here and then
sup states for for long you go to check
it's a day the day only difference from
full tongue is I have three polarization
here I have two polarizations I look at
that when we are square say cubic pi
square so it's a three hots and the way
cubic and this is the by velocity and
the PI square and that D Omega okay so
this is my density of states when I
convert this summation into integration
and I do D Omega so Omega now unlike
light which I integrate from 0 to
infinite now I only go from 0 to Omega D
ok right so it's 0 to Omega D and 3 and
divide by a at the PI by way that's they
you see you know the volume and you also
know the relation between Omega D right
Omega D is the the by velocity that's
the slope here times the wave vector so
equals pi ad so that's a write Omega D
is related to the Debye velocity and the
equivalent lattice constant the bilat
it's cancer so by combine these two
relation I can find what's the
corresponding lattice constant I have
here essentially I saw this I get a PI
ad equals 6 and divide by PI square 1/3
okay and you can also see this is the by
frequency is 6 and way PI square 1/3
times VD so this are they given the
lumber awful atoms per unit volume I
give you a yakuman lattice constant for
the Debye model okay and the rest is
very similar to fold hung right now I'm
going to find out what the total energy
is H Omega times this Bose Einstein
distribution replace with the photon
density of states integrated from 0 to
Omega D right so it's identical
I find out that they now it's something
I can measure for folder I can measure
the energy right so this is a Yule T
temperature say this is more yo is a
capital per unit volume and is 0 to
Omega D and H bar Omega exponential H
bar Omega
KB T nice one then silver states we have
three Omega square and 2 pi square D
Omega R we cubic right we QB this with
the by velocity cubed okay so that's my
what I have here the dents up States
right how many states each state that
have fallen frequency Omega energy H bar
Omega how manifold are in that state
right okay everything looks very similar
differences Omega D rather than infinite
V D rather than speed of light
okay now this is the energy per unit
volume for solid now you can think about
this is crystal you guys you can measure
and when you measure what do you measure
typically for solid you don't you you
say temperature is a say thermodynamic
right here all these are similar but you
measure specific heat you add energy you
say how much time to rise so the
specific heat say per unit volume is a
deal DT right so you take a derivative
of this and now say you can take a do DT
everything is the inside only here is a
temperature right there could be a
little thermal expansion a lattice
constant could be a small functional
temperature but the main change come
from the both an Einstein factor here so
if I take this everything as a constant
I can do
analytically my integration
differentiation and then do the
integration right now let me come back
to here they fold huh
if I do integration is a 3/4 power right
what's a specifically that is specific
does that mean specific here is a tutti
cubic power a low temperature a low
temperature is two cubic right that's
because when you go to very low
temperature this Omega D is in fact it
would be very large because here this is
a small so that see it's like your upper
limit is infinite so a very low
temperature your specific heat is
actually Chi cubic it's just like photon
it's a photon gas so if you plot this
specific heat of most materials what you
find is a trending like this okay
eventually it goes to a constant and the
low temperature this region is a chi
cubic power okay a high temperature is
constant what is it that constant a high
temperature that's it because when we go
high temperature it's no longer
integration to an infinite ok so it
turns out this if you do your
integration goes to that constant value
and this fundamentally is a the equal
partition theory remember we mention
equal partition at high temperature each
mode contribute average speak and 1/2
KBT right
each mode country each issue freedom if
it's the motion to quadratic right so
1/2 KBT so if I think about the atom in
the crystal
I have atom in the crystal a vibrissae a
mole is K X K Y I say you have
one half MV x MV by my Z and with the
square right each one right so you have
three and I have KX square half KX
square that's another energy mode KX
squared KY square KZ square so that's a
six right so at high temperature the
energy of each atom is 6 times 1/2 KBT
that's the energy
now you take a derivative to temperature
because that's specific here so you got
the three KT so this one should be a 3
KB and say number of atoms divided by
per unit volume right so this is deulim
pretty low you know 13 low it's a you
quick partition Theory at a high
temperature low temperature you go to 2
cubed that's right
so what Einstein so the Einstein
actually first proposed a model to
explain specific heat of crystals I
didn't use the by model he used a
constant this Omega e model okay the
Omega E if you do that you don't do
integration you gathered a dense Upstate
mostly so just I have 6 M modes just so
the actual mega times this times 16
months right so if you do Einstein model
you integrate say are you doing
integrate because of this frequencies
only God Einstein already the problem is
when go to low temperature this is an
exponential function and experimentally
was measured a cubic function right
cubic rather explanation so this is a
where say it was proven that Einstein
was not correct okay
specific heat any questions a few more
common the real crystals on either say a
simple Debye or Einstein right if you
look at dispersion right so what
typically do people do is they will
measure to measure specific heat and
they use the by temperature so it's the
KBT D equals H bar Omega D right so you
can say if you can fit you measure
specific heat you feel the Omega D u
divided by Kb you gather the equivalent
to by temperature right so this is a say
T D gives you the by temperature and the
by temperature so you know if you look
at the the real crystal dispersion we
said before right and you can say either
very low temperature acoustical phonons
a most important lower energy once you
go to higher temperature they start to
kick in because the higher energy that
exponent because also important right so
in fact seldom you can use just one
temperature to feed a whole curve so
this Debye temperature sometimes as a
function of temperature okay it's just a
fading really the point I want to make
as an integral you can fit an integral
very easily integrate is forgiving you
made some air
right integration is smudged out you
take a derivatives it's much more
difficult to get to the agree with
experiment so la it turns out many times
we do model for transport properties and
they don't your say most transport
properties are integrals so you say okay
this is a for my field experiment you
often get a beautiful fee doesn't mean
you get things right so that's the what
I want to to see their comment okay so
this is the day we saw with her about
photon we for talk about foolin and what
about electrons right electron you can
again use the same strategy say here is
the energy of the I I go to solve the
dispersion of the electrons and I see
the energy of electrons of the system
due to electron a certain temperature
electron I have to carry chemical
potential right so he and the mule is
summation of polarization that's a spin
up spin down and KX KY KZ and the
electron is energy of that mode right I
normally I don't like to use the H Omega
for H bar Omega for electron I just say
this energy and then they Fermi to rock
right this is the energy of that level I
say the energy and how many electrons
are in the ideal level say as a quantum
state right so this is the energy of the
electron system okay
and of course you can take a derivative
of this against specific hit but you
have one trouble you have an extra
mueller-wright I said before Mew is
close to EF but you still have in series
you have to assure determine them you
right how you determine mu is you have
for your lifetime you have a fixed
number of number of you like one
right so the total number you like Tron
you know in the system and that total
number of electron again I do this
summation yes
so each state the average number of
electron is the Fermi Dirac right so I
have a nice meal KB T plus one so I have
one equation here another equation here
right and using this equation I can say
if you give me an I can find mu I
substitute mu back into here I can which
is the function of temperature mu is the
final temperature right I substitute
back here I take a derivative and now I
have one temperature here and not a
temperature there so it's it's more
complicated right but it's doable
mathematically I'm close problem so I'm
not going to do it I just give it so
they you go to do the electron specific
heat you will find out electron specific
heat approximately metal is 1/2 PI
square and overweight yesterday any is
number of electrons and KBT over here
f TF is the
a Fermi temperature okay so electron
temperature specific heat is a
temperature is a function linearly
proportional to temperature and they so
what so they k TF is a KBT F equals EF
Fermi energy okay so that's the
difference right say times sometimes the
people do model and they all use a
constant specific heat for electron you
can tell them it's wrong because the
electron because the TF is very high
because it's a few electron volt if it's
300 Kelvin is only 26 minutes right from
world
EFE the typically Fermi level is a few
electron volt right few electron divided
by 26 milli electron comes 300 that's
the equivalent Fermi temperature very
high temperature so most of time you're
in this regime okay when temperature is
lower than yeah yeah EF you have the
linear distribution okay any other any
questions I talked about the specific
heat and the other since this is a
Stefan Boltzmann law and when one order
commander is now you can say if you want
to take a derivative that energy of
photon you get specific heat of photon
right we just normally do not talk about
specific heat of photon it's very low
it's hard to measure okay any questions
here
okay if not you see we this is a almost
like you I can just stop here and they
use this result and move on to next
that's a pretty much you take a semester
course on statistical physics you learn
only this stuff one lecture okay we have
what we're the three or four lecture on
solid state and to like your on condom
one lecture on statistical physics
you'll learn everything okay
but I don't want to let you go because
you go talk to others you may still a
pure Eagle or rent yes very good yeah
good question yes so when you talk about
you go to a semiconductor again you have
to use this to find a Fermi level and
then go to that you can still do the
same actually I do not know whether
semiconductor it's linear it's a good
question to check yeah I do not know I I
haven't that really checked them myself
okay so of course what do you learned is
the K is the Fermi Dirac bose-einstein
right and together if you see the second
lecture we learn Maxwell distribution
that's the classical boards my limit
right and but see there are some really
very commonly used terminology in
statistics in statistical thermodynamics
so I don't want to
so dialogue in the test view right and
we we normally do sorry we normally do
not use it so I will not I will not I
need to turn this off forgot it this
time
so what I'm going to use to to really
do laksa is to give you a little bit
introduction to the busy language what
people talk in statistical physics right
it's actually very beautiful treatment
so what are we here is fundamentals I
would say in statistical physics okay so
what are the fundamental concept yes
right this is a well this is the let's
say I have listened you saw quantum
mechanics so you know the you know the
energy level say let's suppose you have
say photon immediate at a certain
frequency
right so that's the energy of this same
mode you'll actually my gravity mode so
if I have standing wave here that's a
actual my granny mode right and the so
one photon with that mode that has a
corresponding frequency the energy is H
Omega this
right so what do you say is that the
probable what are you asking why this is
not the probable energy density it is a
probable energy density it's just a
normal a the deviation is really really
really small so you measure it there you
can always measure some fluctuations
right and but say this is a that
division from that fluctuation will be
very very small in fact that's a very
interesting topic itself okay yeah so
the concept we want to say is in when we
do statistics we want to do time average
right so I can normally I cannot measure
a very far say let's suppose I have with
the internal energy right it's a
fluctuating over time and I have to do
if I do error any measurement I have to
over a certain time I will integrate
that say quantity over this time I get a
time average that's what I can measure
right nobody can say I'm going to
measure really instantaneous an engineer
so that's a time average e of any
quantity right and this is a system I
have and I measure the average quantity
by in statistics it's hard to do time
treatment the time tremenda you you you
you are neither to read the chapter turn
off my book I don't know whether I can
get there okay that's another direction
when you do statistics it's due time to
invent time averaging right but say
water say people normally do is rather
than doing time element or treatment
there look how the in-sample is like a
more doing space treatment right what's
in sample so
in some boy is this a collection all for
Honam state right let's say this system
right
it's a macroscopic system i if i suppose
i can so quantum mechanics right I can
find an all quantum state of this system
right the total amber holder of quantum
state quantum states let's say total
amber is Omega right so in when I
construct example I look HIDA each
quantum state is a one system each of
this as a one system okay you can you
can see that's a huge huge number right
and in each of this quantum state this
quantity has certain value right I may
have a quantum state where say all you
like I say all say oh there's no
particular right that in that case today
is this it's the energy of that whole
system in that constant is zero okay so
I each of this I have see this quantity
and then what I do is the in sample
average is what's the probability so now
I'm saying the probability of observing
this quantum state is P so what I do is
X I P I and some up that I sum up all
one state in this in sample
so here I have time average here is an
example
Everage so in statistical treatment is
mostly treating this in sample average
and turns out there are different
different probability distribution
depends on whether this example the
system I'm treating is at a constant
temperature or constant energy where
there is a closed system or whether it's
an open system okay so those are
different examples and where we're going
in there at the beginning of next
lecture I'm going to discuss this in
some boys we started with the basic
example microcanonical it's a closed
system constant energy and going to a
system that's a constant temperature
when a system is constant temperature
means it can actually change it with the
surrounding the energy to maintain the
constant temperature but closed in there
we go through last days if I have hotter
exchange with the surrounding mass
transfer right then I have grand
canonical so your goal from gives this
probability to boards my factor now say
no boards my boards my principle two
boards my factor two gives factor with
this different and sample treatment okay
so that's where I I just wanted to say
where we go in but I wanted to use some
time to look either toward the bit
surfing right so
okay so what I'm going to first let's
look at the ends up States
okay so let's look at a full on density
of states so even though I everything
looked a very see we give an analytic
expression if you really look at the
photon photons Omega square right with
just a you stick and you see here is not
exactly Omega square see this region
very low frequency region that's a
linear that's the that's where it look
more Omega square right once you go to
up your photons right transfers
non-shooter up your full-on they say
it's a lot longer that I say Omega
square is no longer the picture and when
we calculate energy remember well
integrating over a density of States for
the Einstein distribution right we are
using our parabola probiotic
distribution to represent this function
how good it is you should not feel very
uncomfortable right but people use it
okay and a different mature system so so
what what what is so here is again this
is the where I'm going to be Debye
approximation is Phi and this those are
they typically when you have different
direction
different she transfers up your phone I
say acoustic follow you get here the
after phonons
okay right so people downloadable this
is a you can you can do mostly by
competition you can also do some say use
a neutron to measure it electron density
of states right
oh well so here with this look this is
like quantum well we discuss right it's
a staircases and this is a probably
quantum wires their spikes okay
tosses are more isolated lines and
that's the typical parabolic
approximation we use right and you have
to look either let's say where's your
fancy where's your EF so you like Tron
fine structure
let's see Oh for what
silicon again
okay so so firstly you have to go to
look at the where is the Fermi level
fill to the top right and and then say
for transport what do you really care if
you look at the electron transport you
should look at that where what what so
the dense upstate near their formidable
because that's where a KBT we said right
is if it's too far away this region well
most likely it's not involved in
transmit they are feel the electron now
we like to move there so you look how
the what's interesting is really what
the density of states near the Fermi
level and give you another well resonant
levels let's look at this okay what is
this so sometimes right what people say
okay if you dope a semiconductor you put
a say say e my CFS of zero is the EVF
here right and you put an atom in and
say you put a some impurity atoms and
they could have created some shaft
features in the density of states and
this shaft feature could be very
interesting for transport because if you
have shellfish or means there could be a
lot of charge there right and the
velocity of this carrier is the slope
okay it's the if I have right so it's
the slope group velocity is the slope of
this line dispersion is so so typically
in exam we do when do thermoelectrics we
like those who have the those shaft
features because I say I'd like to have
the to have a lot of charge
so that I can have high electric
conductivity the tens'up states times
they write the lumber density is C F
times D and if the D is large my I could
potentially get a very high number
density and then say of course I have to
care about the other properties so I
have to align my Fermi level and how i
line my Fermi level is by controlling
the doping so I can change the doping
and change that Fermi level so I thought
I'll stop here any questions I was
looking at the papers and I could go to
if you go to later physics today for a
website for example you'll see people
are doing it doing cold atoms what are
cold atoms mean you know you will be
related to both our Einstein
condensation not of [ __ ] on cold atoms
okay
you